tant de monde au fléau bien sûr tout le
monde a vu batman arpenté les rues de
taubaté avec sa cape et son costume
depuis quelques jours il fait la une des
médias
déguisé en batman cet ancien policier a
repris du service pour faire régner
l'ordre n'ont pas gotham city
mais à taubaté une ville du brésil je
vais durant les temps un super héros je
veux faire comprendre aux gens que la
drogue ne rend pas heureux
bien au contraire un phénomène mondial
une nouvelle espèce de citoyens
ordinaires qui ont décidé de jouer les
justiciers masqués en passons à l'action
cet homme n'est pas un cambrioleur c'est
un assureur qui veut lutter contre le
crime and the mask et organise des
patrouilles à seattle pour débusquer les
délinquants un mouvement qui prend de
l'ampleur
combien sont ils
personne ne sait avec certitude mais
selon ces super-héros anonymes ils
pourraient être 200 à veiller sur et si
leur nom de scène prête à sourire
je suis si mitron ces super héros ne
sont pas là pour rigoler car ils se sont
investis d'une véritable mission
beaucoup de personnes ont perdu la foi
en leur gouvernement en elle même et en
leurs dirigeants et nous nous
représentons une forme d'espoir pour ce
pays
alors qui sont ces aventuriers masqué de
véritable ange gardien ou des anonymes
en quête de gloire
allez au suivant jusqu'où sont ils prêts
à aller pour être à la hauteur de leur
mission
on m'a tiré dessus au moins à 33
reprises j'ai été touché une fois et on
m'a poignardé trois fois rencontre avec
ces héros d'un nouveau genre tout droit
sorti d'une autre galaxie
une cape en cuir rouge en collants
moulants
à callebasse ici une petite ville des
philippines à 2h de manille superman est
comme chez lui un citoyen pas vraiment
ordinaire que tout le monde se réjouit
de voir déambuler dans les rues
[Musique]
il ressemble vraiment à superman on
dirait le vrai je suis très content
parce qu'ils m'apprécient quand je suis
en superman ce sont mes amis du marché
quoi ils notoriété qui dépasse les
frontières de son quartier superman
alias herbert chavez est une star
nationale
il est la coqueluche de tous les médias
de son pays qui s'amuse de sa passion
extrême pour le super héros mais n'allez
pas croire que ce philippin de 35 ans
deviennent superman seulement devant les
caméras toute sa vie est dédié à son
idole vous êtes ici devant ma maison la
maison de superman et le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que chez herbert
chavez superman se reproduit plus vite
que les gremlins dessin ici vous pouvez
voir toute ma collection
il y à mes petits superman et ça c'est
un de mes préférés c'est kent superman
j'aimerais vraiment avoir le même visage
que lui
salon cuisine salle de bain cela fait 30
ans que ce philippin voue un culte aux
héros venu de la planète krypton
c'est mon lit quand j'étais écolier
c'est un original ils datent des années
90 ça c'est ma toute première casquette
là vous avez tous mes trophées je les ai
gagnées dans des concours de déguisement
je porte tous les jours un tee shirt de
superman est belle mais mon caleçon csu
quand même mais si herbert chavez à
toute la panoplie
pas question pour lui de jouer les
justiciers son unique obsession
ressembler le plus possible à superman
et pour ça pas de super miracle à part
ces lentilles bleues comme le regard
laser de christopher reeves ce philippin
doit sa métamorphose au bistouri
ça c'est moi avant vous pouvez voir la
différence
une transformation débuté il y à 16 ans
herbert chavez a subi tellement
d'opérations qu'il ne se rappelle même
plus combien
attends je dois raconter un deux trois
c'est quoi la 9e agen ça doit faire 11
en fait 1998 j'ai commencé par le nez
puis en 2000 j'ai voulu avoir cette
fosse est la même que superman
après ça j'ai fait refaire les lèvres du
collagène partout ici je me suis aussi
fait opérer du ventre trois fois de
liposuccion devant et sur les côtés
d'anna j'ai aussi eu des injections et
des médicaments pour avoir la peau plus
blanche et le plus douloureux reste à
venir
ma prochaine opération à ça sera pour
avoir de belles fesses et après je me
faire implanter des abdominaux
et peu importe kerber chavez est quelque
peu perdu de son identité au fil des ans
il est toujours le héros de ses parents
il n'y a pas tant de changements que ça
dans son visage
vous savez il a toujours beaucoup
ressembler à superman
la seule différence c'est le menton il
n'avait pas cette fosse est là quand il
était plus jeune
nous on est heureux il est très beau
notre fils il faut dire que ses parents
qui tiennent une boutique de
déguisements ne sont pas étrangers à la
passion de leur fils aujourd'hui grâce à
la notoriété d'herbert les affaires
familiales n'ont jamais aussi bien
marché
peron déconner on ne s'attendait pas à
tous tirer profit de son addiction à
superman
aujourd'hui nous avons beaucoup de
succès avec le costume on est même
devenu très célèbre ici grâce à ça et on
est devenus riches aussi tout ça grâce à
superman enfin pas si riche que ça quand
même
pour entretenir sa popularité herbert
participe régulièrement à des
rassemblements de super héros comme
aujourd'hui dans ce centre commercial de
manille maquillage soigné coiffure
millimétré et costumes ajustés avec
l'aide de son assistant il faut une
bonne heure à air verte pour se
transformer en superman
[Musique]
tout à son rôle de super héros herberth
en deviendrait presque inaccessible plus
tard qu sauveur de l'humanité
suivant superman c'est le vrai superman
des philippines
c'est lui le vrai mac le vrai mec sait
qui c'est super mal
si tous ici se contente d'être des
sosies de super héros d'autres ont
décidé de passer à l'action et de
traquer les criminels
seattle au nord ouest des états unis
dans cette ville des citoyens se sont
découvert une vocation de justicier
masqué des super héros qui ont choisi
pour que j'aie un magasin de bd c'est
ici qu'ils se donnent rendez-vous pour
leurs patrouilles quotidiennes avec moi
c'est fini je suis le leader ego des
super héros de seattle est un groupe de
super héros et on essaie de limiter la
violence dans les rues voilà pitch black
manager minatd jacques carel caballero
ralph lauren et captain karma
[Musique]
mais pour combattre le crime quand on
n'a pas de super pouvoirs mieux vaut
avoir un super équipements j'ai un gilet
pare-balles en dessous de ma combi ne
voyez là j'ai mon talkie walkie pour
communiquer avec mes gars c'est un spray
au poivre afghans sont renforcées au cas
où je dois taper sur quelqu'un je serai
plus fort comme ça j'ai des chaussures
de sécurité aussi et ça c'est la partie
la plus importante de mon équipement
avec cette caméra je filme les
délinquants et pour eux la partie est
finie dans le groupe chacun prend son
rôle très au sérieux
les acolytes de phoenix se voit comme
des sauveurs de la patrie vaste
programme
[Musique]
j'aime ce jeu c'est que nous avons pas
mal de problèmes en ce moment beaucoup
de personnes ont perdu la foi alors
gouvernement en est le même en leurs
dirigeants et nous nous représentons une
forme d'espoir pour ce pays à la nuit
tombée
new super héros passent à l'action
parlons de la patrouille de ce soir
purple sur un mât secondes et je vais
avoir deux secondes ce soir amina jack
sera mon autre second mon troisième sera
el caballero
j'ai besoin que tu sois flottant je pars
en chasse avec purple et les gars ok
tout le monde est prêt vous avez bien
compris vos rôles
si vous avez des questions n'hésitez pas
à croquer on y va cela fait deux ans que
phoenix jones patrouillent dans les rues
de seattle
c'est après le braquage de sa voiture
qu'il a décidé de se lancer à la
poursuite des criminels
mon fils a été blessé ce jour j'étais
très en colère je me suis dit qu'il
n'était pas question que la même chose
arrive à quelqu'un d'autre
et pour remplir leur mission les
justiciers masqués vont même jusqu'à
utiliser les données de la police
j'ai accès à la carte des crimes de
seattle je peux voir où il ya le plus de
clément ville et où il faut qu'on aille
on se concentre généralement sur ce
quartier c'est lacombe patrouillons la
plupart du temps pour l'instant tout à
l'air calme pas un criminel à l'horizon
mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas
l'année dernière l'histoire a bien
failli mal tourner un super-héros accusé
de rejoindre les forces du mal alors
est-il un super héros ou un super
problèmes techniques john se retrouve
devant les tribunaux
passant du statut de héros à celui
d'accusé après une intervention qui a
dégénéré paul traces
la police a arrêté un homme qui se fait
appeler phoenix jones pour agression
j'étais en train de marcher dans la rue
principale
jusque là sur la 1re avenue et on a vu
une grosse bagarre avec plein de gens
donc je suis venu jusqu'ici et je leur
ai demandé d'arrêter
une bagarre immortalisé par la caméra de
l'équipe du super héros qui filme toutes
ses interventions
[Applaudissements]
ces moments là une fille a commencé à me
taper dessus avec ses chaussures
j'essayais de l'esquivé pour ne pas
prendre un coup dans la figure et dans
la bagarre j'ai dû envoyer du jeu au
poivre sur un type
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
là la police est arrivée et m'a arrêté
moi je devais arrêter ce petit jeu que
j'avais causés à ces problèmes chance
technique jones qui se voyait comme un
bon samaritain se retrouve derrière les
barreaux pendant quelques heures et se
voit confisquer toutes les armes de
défense par la police de seattle
s'il se promène dans la rue qui porte
son costume qu'il se fait prendre en
photo ou signe des autographes
nous nous n'avons pas de problème avec
ça vous savez quoi c'est super mais
notre véritable inquiétude
ça a toujours été sa sécurité et celle
des autres pour safety alors qu'il
laisse la lutte contre le crime aux
professionnels et qu'il se contente de
porter son costume témoignage finalement
felix jones a été relaxé mais cette
comparution l'a obligé à révéler sa
véritable identité
je suis phoenix et john je suis aussi
bonnes feuilles d'or messi désormais
tout le monde connaît son nom ben fodor
ne veux donner aucun détail sur sa vraie
vie tout juste sait-on qu'il a 24 ans
deux enfants et que sa femme n'est autre
que purple rain sa fidèle coéquipières
qui n'accepte de parler que de leur
complicité sur le terrain
vous savez on pense de la même manière
tous les deux quand il voit quelque
chose dans la rue on se comprend tout de
suite sans avoir besoin de se dire quoi
que ce soit on se couvrent mutuellement
probablement plus qu'avec les autres
membres du court mais ce soir notre
couple de super héros ne pourra pas nous
montrer l'étendue de ses pouvoirs
seattle est sagement endormi phoenix
peut tout de même se consoler avec ses
nombreux fans
oh
phoenix jones est un de mes sujets de
prédilection dans les dîners j'ai deux
petits garçons qui grandissent et le
monde a besoin de plus de super héros
des super héros qui à défaut de sauver
le monde continue de faire rêver
[Musique]